[Musique]
à sidiailles rémy vient tranquillement à
bout du parcours noir d'accrobranche
décidément ce garçon est inépuisable
assez fun en tout cas ça met en jambes
c'est sûr donc là il nous reste à peu
près 3 km c'est ça faire un peu bref
ensuite tu vas aller disque hop on est
sur des 33 tours on consomme pieds
joints ans sauf pieds joints
en choisissant le parcours noir
l'aventurier s'est attaqué à une
spécialité de l'accrobranche inspiré par
les obstacles du trech beaucoup de
balancier tu m'étonnes que les gamins
ils peuvent pas tous faire beaucoup de
cordage devrait quand même pu mettre des
trucs un peu plus fixés dans le thé dans
le noir ils sont complètement malade ici
en général les grimpeurs boucle ce
parcours en 45 minutes
mais là ça traîne en longueur on sent
que rémy a encore un peu de son trail
matinale sur les mollets joie aussi a
pas que de la force brute et beaucoup d'
équilibre quand même mais à vaincre sans
péril on triomphe sans gloire
c'est d'autant plus important que la
récompense ici vaut le détour
la maxi tyrolienne de 400 m dont tu as
besoin que je sois là pour t'assurer ça
va aller je vais m'en sortir
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
il faut quand même
ou cela j'arrive
[Musique]
comme ça
poussé par le glissement rémy va
atteindre les 50 km heure de quoi
terminer la journée en fanfare
[Applaudissements]
en comme ça décoiffe c'est très
intéressant
faut arrêter c'est ça moi ça envoie sans
voix extra franchement très belles
sensations ça conclut bien la journée
entre le travail ce matin qui montre
vraiment un côté très nature et puis
toutes les belles choses qu'on peut
retrouver avec un gros dénivelés et puis
l'accrobranche ici avec eux enfin ça
renvoie quoi ça c'est franchement c'est
très très sympa peut facilement passer
la journée ici du coup c'est génial
comme quoi en plein air on peut vraiment
s'éclater un choc une paire de baskets
et la journée fait les gars moi je vous
propose qu'on retourne là bas et qu'on
s'en fasse une petite dernière
c'est parti on y va je vous en parle
[Musique]